today we're talking about being greener
with google cloud google cloud armor in
the wild and a google maps red pin
makeover i'm daryl ducharme and welcome
to this week in cloud where we review
the lowest latency news caluza is a
software as a service company that helps
to accelerate the shift to a zero-carbon
world
their technology stack spans a
multi-cloud estate and it's especially
easy to get emissions data from google
cloud applications thanks to the carbon
footprint solution
from houses to vehicles and beyond
calooza is using technology to make the
energy transition a simple and
affordable option for our clients and
their customers read their full story on
the blog recently a google cloud armor
customer was targeted with a series of
https ddos attacks which peaked at 46
million requests per second
the largest layer 7 ddos reported to
date
cloud armor adaptive protection was able
to detect and analyze the traffic early
in the attack lifecycle ensuring the
customer service stayed online and
continued serving their end users
more exciting details on the blog
if you're using google maps on
javascript android and ios you may
notice that the iconic red pin got a
makeover
no action is required for you to use the
new pin design and custom marker
implementations in your apps will not be
affected to learn more about the newest
version of the default marker check out
the blog if you want to read more about
these announcements or see a full list
check out the link
any thoughts or ideas leave us a comment
or tweet us we'll see you in the cloud